it looks like the hotels closed down
hello anybody in welcome nice for you
I'm Vera D thank you first name is Liza
Liza good to see how are you doing today
this is this the boss man caught it and
where's the other half corner shoes
what's rule I don't use it for anything
actually Wow what's out there that was
here when I got here believe it or not
that's what sale
apparently so so he went onto the beach
pick up some driftwood and then dipped
it in some varnish yep
$22 same as that one over there no
inside no have you sold any of these
never seriously and how much for the
t-shirts between $12 for employees and
$18 for guests so staff have to pay for
their own t-shirts yes and for the
guests their $18 yes Wow so when was
last time you sold a t-shirt I sell them
every day but mostly to the employees
employees yes how long we've been here
the establishments been here almost
three years I've been here almost three
years as well what's wrong with it from
your point of view noise levels you know
especially the one directly above the
restaurant that what kind of noise cuz
it's not the the music and the people
the foot traffic everybody hanging out
at the bar and things of that nature so
that goes on that directly underneath
yes they end up being refunded and then
they end up putting us on blast on all
of these you know websites and social
media and just bad reviews left and
right housekeeping
back except for touch base with the
housekeepers
I'm just out of interest if Gordon here
just checked in how far away are the
[ __ ] rooms I mean you sound like
you're miles away hello madam so room 16
right this way
what's that thing that we grill our
wings on it you grill your wings on it
yes how often you grill wings in there
every stinking day Wow Jesus in fact I
think there's a wing left in there
when was that grilled chances are could
have been yesterday those are the extra
crispy ones and who's responsible for
this the kitchen handles all of this end
of it of course you found another
charbroiled and these were done
yesterday I believe so and they cook
every day on here yes I know the
customers still alive right room 16 yes
sir this is your Caribbean building the
Caribbean Caribbean Caribbean yes what
part of this resembles the Caribbean I
think it's more so because of the view
are the view right here sir thank you
very much very welcome enjoy thank you
thank you
Wow Wow
stinks in here
there's a very sort of damp musty smell
bloody hell oh the bed feels like it's
15 years old
smells of place is filthy really bars
absolutely disgusting $180 of iron for
this [ __ ]
Wow minibar consisting absolutely fuchal
freezer over frozen and defrosted about
10 years ago what a mess